der äquator mit globetrotter darm
spezialist für niedere derivat mit
globetrotter punkt ch
wir sind unterwegs mit den plänen einen
uhr folgen malaysia die nächsten fünf
tage leben wir so wie ihre vorfahren von
und mit dem regenwald
zum leben der plan gehört seit jeher das
jagen
schon nach wenigen stunden haben die
jäger glück eine riesen pythonschlange
[Musik]
es wird das mittagessen bevor es
weitergeht in den urwald hinein
auf der mission sind drei generationen
an dabei sie alle sind als nomaden im
urwald aufgewachsen
erst seit kurzem leben sie in dörfern
ich fühle mich hier im urwald wach und
lebendig in meinem kopf fühle ich mich
frei und leicht
ich sehe die großen bäume das
blätterdach die früchte
das alles macht mich glücklich und ich
kann meine gedanken lösen von den
holzfällern
[Musik]
in der letzten folge hat sich lubin mit
seinen getreuen auf die reise gemacht
ihre mission ist klar sie wollen ihren
urwald vor dem abholzen retten
mit einer land rechts klage dafür
brauchen sie beweise
im inselstaat kiribati der präsident die
hoffnung aufgegeben das land vor dem
steigenden meeresspiegel zu schützen
währenddessen verabschiedet sich jutta
biener von der familie für die erste
reise ihres lebens
[Musik]
in kenia hat mary ihre erste fahrstunde
absolvierte aus dem bauernmädchen wird
mehr und mehr eine selbstbewusste junge
frau
und in singapur schließlich erfährt die
ärztin und unternehmerin george ali dass
sie künftig das aushängeschild der
asiatischen mode vereinigung wert
[Musik]
lupen und seine leute in einem der
letzten urwälder die ihrem volk
geblieben sind sie kartografieren um
beweismittel zu haben für eine land
rechtslage dem ort den sie hier
vermessen ist eine wildschwein schule
für die berner die jäger und sammler ein
platz von existenzieller bedeutung schon
ihre urahnen jagten hier darum machen
wir diese karte mit alten historischen
plätzen um zu beweisen dass wir planen
hier schon seit generationen als
normalen leben und dabei orte wie diesen
hier nutzen internationale holzkonzerne
haben in den letzten 30 jahren mehr als
zwei drittel des waldgebietes dpa
niedergewalzt und dies mit dem segen der
regierung schon der schweizer bruno
manser kämpft er an der seite der plan
gegen die abholzung bis er spurlos
verschwand die klage ist die letzte
chance für die pen an den kleinen rest
zu retten sie das urvolk kartografieren
mit moderner technik mittels gps dem
positionierungssystem via satellit
diesen ort hier hatten wir noch nicht
kapiert ihr kartieren in unserem urwald
alle wichtigen historischen orte hier
geht der weg runter ins tal wo die
vielen bäume stehen
diese bäume tragen früchte die die vögel
und wildschweine sehr mögen es ist ein
wichtiger weg den unsere leute auf ihrer
wanderschaft seit generationen gehen
[Musik]
bis heute hat mary neben unserer
filmcrew weiße menschen nur von weitem
gesehen
das wird sich heute nachmittag ändern
doch vorerst geht es am frühen morgen
mit josef zu den tieren
wir werden jetzt in die savanne fahren
und ich werde dir zeigen wie du den
touristen die wilden tiere erklären
kannst und wo du sie findest josef ist
an der schule angestellt
er war einst selber schüler der
kieskuhle inzwischen ist er ein
erfahrener guide
ich lerne viel überredet hier und vor
allem darüber wie sie den leuten näher
zu bringen sind
josef was ihr viel nun werde ich selber
immer mehr wissen und immer wieder
werden
siehst du die giraffen
[Musik]
die giraffen können viereinhalb meter
hoch werden die giraffen männchen und
weibchen kann man unterscheiden wenn man
ihre hörner betrachtet die männchen
haben keine haare auf den hörnern die
weibchen hingegen schon
[Musik]
die ärztin john daly ist eine stilikone
in singapur und eine unternehmerin mit
eigene kosmetiklinie
da darf sie an keinem event fehlen
publizität belebt das geschäft
[Musik]
zur gleichen zeit an der berühmten
orchard road in singapur
john daly stylist joshua auf
einkaufstour
zusammen mit seiner chefin fliegt er für
einen business trip nach bangkok da
braucht frau doktor ein paar neue teile
seit sieben jahren kaufte das teil ist
ein
der chef ihnen fehlt dafür die zeit doch
er hat gute unterstützung
normalerweise kauf ich die sachen in
gedanken in georgia das ist doch
erstaunlich wenn er in paris ist ruft er
mich an und sagt ich sehe etwas das
wirklich sehr gut zum georgia passen
könnte kann ich den fotos schicken
das ist sehr nett und deutscher weiß es
zu schätzen das vergisst sie nie für den
teil antritt könnte das sehr gut zumal
der rücken ist sehr schön mit den
flügeln joshua hat kein unbeschränktes
budget und trotzdem wenn wir etwas sehen
das unglaublich teuer ist besprechen wir
aber wenn sie sich in das kleid verliebt
spielt der preis eigentlich keine rolle
bitte sagen sie das nicht immer
das ist dann wirklich sehr schönes kleid
genießt die zeit in bangkok zehn minuten
einkauf drei neue kleider für
umgerechnet 21.000 fanden an der
modenschau scheint george ali in
gedanken bereits bei ihrem business trip
in bangkok zu sein
[Applaus]
[Musik]
auf carrie was passt das wetter
zustimmung unserer hauptfigur jutta
biener zusammen mit der umweltaktivistin
claire verlässt sie das erste mal im
leben ihr fleckchen heimat
[Musik]
ehrlich gesagt habe ich angst vor dem
flug es regnet stark und das wetter ist
stürmisch
außerdem ist es das erste mal dass ich
in einem flugzeug sitzen werde
er wird genau
für drei tage geht es auf die insel aber
young
die umweltaktivistin claire möchte
youtube ina dort eine art atlantis
zeigen ein dorf das der mehr komplett
zum opfer gefallen ist
mach dir keine sorgen wir werden nicht
vom himmel fallen
das wird schon gut gehen die
formalitäten am flughafen beschränkten
sich auf ein minimum
das wichtigste das gewicht das
kleinflugzeug hat nur beschränkte
kapazität
[Musik]
ich kann mir einfach nicht vorstellen
dass das mehr ein ganzes dorf erspart
um das zu glauben muss ich es mit
eigenen augen sehen
[Musik]
es ist soweit
not-op das erste große reise beginnt 20
minuten flugzeit
[Musik]
gut 17.000 km östlich in kenia ist mary
auf safari bei den tieren
aber es geht für die angehende touristen
guide auch um ihre zukünftigen kunden
du musst den touristen alles erklären
haben denn sie haben oft viel gearbeitet
und sind sehr weit gereiste näher zu
kommen
das darfst du nicht vergessen wenn die
besucher durch etwas fragen musst du
ihnen stets freundlich und sehr
detailliert sagen was du weißt es ist
sehr wichtig für einen guide wirklich
alles zu wissen
das wissen über diese wunderschönen
tiere und pflanzen ist die voraussetzung
dafür dass du ein guter geist
[Musik]
hier pariert
seht ihr die babys war wir müssen jeden
tag drei dinge tun sie müssen spielen
wie die kleinen her
sie müssen ihr fell putzen und sie
müssen futter finden
indem es sein futter
[Musik]
eine glückliche fabian fangen wir wie
diese macht jeden tag diese drei dinge
den abend und die nacht verbringen sie
auf den bäumen
eigentlich will josef mary noch löwen
zeigen
aber es ist zu spät löwen sind
nachtaktiv
doch mary wird entschädigt
relevant
[Musik]
als mary aus ihrem kleinen weiler an die
schule im masai mara park kam war sie
schüchtern fast ängstlich
mit jedem schultag als sie mutiger und
selbstbewusster traut sich mehr zu es
ist ein traum dass ich mit den touristen
hinausfahren und ihnen etwas beibringen
kann
ich werde glücklich sein dass ich
autofahren kann auch weil es hier in der
region sehr selten ist dass frauen auto
fahren und ich werde sehr glücklich
seien viele wunderbare dinge zu wissen
und zu können
im gegensatz zu mary jutta biener und
lupen deren leben sich ausnahmslos am
äquator abspielt hat charlie singapur
verlassen
sie ist in bangkok
[Musik]
wir treffen sie in einem hotelzimmer
es ist früh am morgen in einer stunde
muss sie in einer high end klinik einen
vortrag halten
es ist eine art antritts vortragen denn
erst vor kurzem wurde sie in den
beraterstab der beauty abteilung des
spitals gewählt wie immer dabei ihre
heinzelmännchen und die kleider aus der
boutique in singapur
[Musik]
die zeit drängt doch hektik kommt nicht
auf
ich habe viele vorträge gehalten in den
letzten jahren trotzdem habe ich immer
noch ein bisschen lampenfieber
mein mann sagt dass das gut ist wenn man
kein lampenfieber mehr hat fühlt man
sich zu sicher und kann sich nicht
verbessern
[Musik]
je länger man mit george ali unterwegs
ist desto mehr bekommt man den eindruck
sie brauche eine 24 stunden rund um
betreuung und trotzdem wirkt sie auch
immer etwas verloren
einsam mit sich selber
eigentlich fühle ich mich immer allein
ich mag es wenn viele leute um mich
herum aber eigentlich fühle ich mich
alleine in meinen gedanken auch am
wochenende wenn ich bei meiner familie
bin bin ich immer am arbeiten
anrufe sie oft an
ich weiß nicht ob das sinn macht ich
habe viele leute aber ich fühle mich
alleine denn niemand kann deine probleme
wirklich lösen
ich meine meine assistentin traurig
hundertprozentig sie würde sich für mich
sogar in die schusslinie werfen
[Gelächter]
doch erstmal muss sie sich mit profaner
an problemen rumschlagen
[Musik]
neben dem kartografieren wird ihr jeden
tag gejagt die gruppe lebt von dem was
der urwald hergibt
zuerst gilt es den richtigen gift baum
zu finden
[Musik]
ich bin
nachdem kerben in den baum geschlagen
wurden
fließt das giftige latex direkt in den
bambus köcher
[Musik]
wir werden beim eindecken sehen wozu das
gift von diesem baum gut ist schwächeres
gift brauchen wir zum jagen von nashorn
flügeln stärkeres gift kann auch affen
töten oder kleinere hirsche oder
wildschweine auch wenn der fluss
frisches wasser führt kannst du fische
jagen
juden und muslime sind bereit für die
jagd ruster in der alte jäger lebt noch
heute die ganze zeit im urwald und ist
fast täglich auf der pirsch und lebt
heute in einem dorf und kennt das jahren
aus seiner jugendzeit für die kamera
hatte die traditionelle plan kleidung
angezogen
das ist unsere traditionelle kleidung
für den mann mit den farben gelb weiß
und rot es symbolisiert wofür für uns
der urwald steht
es sind symbole für frieden harmonie und
entspanntheit
dafür stehen diese drei farben das hier
ist unser traditionelles jagd gerät das
blasrohr jeder ab in an man sollte ein
glasrohr bei sich tragen zum blasrohr
gehört der kirche darin haben wir zwei
sorten von pfeilen mit dem größeren
schießen wir größere tiere wie etwa
hirsche oder wildschweine auf der
pfeilspitze haben wir das gift schon
aufgetragen
bei den kleineren pfeilen brauchen wir
kein gift die brauchen wir für kleinere
tiere vögel oder kleine affen
nach kurzer zeit erstellen sie eine
gruppe die von affen hussein versucht
sie anzulocken
[Musik]
nur 1800 kilometer entfernt eine
komplett andere welt
die boom room grad klinik in bangkok
gemäss eigenwerbung einer der zehn
besten kliniken weltweit das spital hat
eine schönheits abteilung und dort ist
george allisat kurzum als beraterin
tätig wir sind stolz dass wir einen
hochkarätigen beraterstab engagieren
konnten heißen sie mit mir drj alle
herzlich willkommen unsere beraterin für
nichtchirurgische schönheitsmedizin
vielen dank darf ich die ihre haben
jetzt das ihr zum team gehören
das ist ein gut aus herzlichen dank
es entbehrt nicht einer gewissen ironie
ausgerechnet die ärztin für die mode so
wichtig ist sie mit ihren x1000 kleidern
muss in einen xl arztkittel auftreten
jalali hält einen vortrag über ihre
schönheitsklinik in singapur
aber sie wäre nicht so reilly wenn sie
nicht auch gleich noch ihre
kosmetikprodukte bewerben würde
[Musik]
die insel aber eines der 33er tolle von
kiribati na und die umweltaktivistin
claire sind auf dem weg zu einem
untergegangenen dorf begleitet werden
sie von pater martin dem insel priester
das meer ist immer in sichtweite ein
insel lidl bis sich die landschaft
plötzlich ändert
[Musik]
hier hat das mehr zugeschlagen
das salzwasser teile der insel in eine
mondlandschaft verwandelt hier stand
einmal ein ganzes dorf
das war alles fruchtbares land hier und
jetzt nur noch salziges meerwasser
sie haben einen schutzdamm nachdem an
bord umsonst
die wieder
bei mir zuhause ist das ganz genauso
wieder hinten an der küste ich habe
direkt am meer bei ebbe ist es ganz weit
weg
bei flut kannst es macht mich traurig
das zu sehen
ich wollte nicht glauben das ist so
schlimm ist hier schon und das mehr
frisst sich immer weiter
ich habe viele jahre lang nicht an die
theorie vom klimawandel geglaubt und dem
immer wieder sprachen aber ich musste
die fakten anerkennen
das wetter und die gezeiten wird immer
schlimmer der meeresspiegel steigt das
sehen wir hier sehr unglücklich und
unser trinkwasser wird auch die
maßanzüge
[Musik]
lupen und hossein jagen nicht zum
vergnügen sondern weil die ganze gruppe
auf ihrer reise auf nahrung aus dem
urwald angewiesen ist
[Musik]
im moment sind keine tiere am wasser
aber hier gibt es aufdrehe und hirsche
und eben noch gebombt und makaken wir
warten hier und dann haben wir eine
chance sie mit dem blasrohr zu erlegen
[Musik]
fabian hat das meer große teile der
insel verschluckt die bewohner dieser
hütten mussten längst umgesiedelt werden
das bringt die umweltaktivistin claire
in rage
ich frage mich wer trägt die schuld an
den ganzen wir leben hier im einklang
mit der natur
die reichen industrieländer sind einzig
daran interessiert dass es ihrer
wirtschaft gut geht und verursachen so
den klimawandel und wir hier am anderen
ende der welt müssen darunter leiden
das macht mich traurig und wütend
hier hat pater macht ihn jeden morgen
die messe gelesen
die kirche war jeweils voll sagte er
wir müssen der realität ins auge schauen
dieser kirche steht symbolisch für das
was ihr passiert die menschen werden
nach und nach ihre dörfer aufgeben
müssen
und irgendwann wird niemand mehr erleben
können es macht mich ziemlich fertig das
hier zu sein
das war ein dorf voller leben genau wie
mainz und jetzt alles und die leute
[Musik]
wer sich an der koranschule zum guide
ausbilden lässt der muss genauso viel
über menschen wissen wie über tiere und
pflanzen
deshalb kommen zweimal wöchentlich und
ehre aus der ganzen welt an die schule
sie erzählen und beantworten fragen
das aufeinandertreffen unterschiedlicher
kulturen führt immer wieder zu
irritationen auf beiden seiten
sind die schweden polizei was polizei
bis es erlaubt es ein mann mehr als eine
frau heiratet wenn ich das richtig
verstanden habe dann könnt ihr sieben
frauen haben und drei freundinnen bei
uns gibt es das nicht
für viele schüler sind diese gespräche
der erste kontakt mit einer person aus
einer anderen welt geben diese erfahrung
hat die schulleitung im verlauf der neun
jahre gemacht indem hier guides
ausgebildet werden
am anfang stellten wir fest dass wenn
unsere schulabgänger mit der arbeit
anfangen sie oft sehr scheu sind
gegenüber den gästen das viel zeit
brauchen um zu verstehen dass weiße
menschen sind wie wir
auch wenn sie weiß sind rund zahlende
gäste wir haben deshalb ein volunteer
programm ins leben gerufen in diesem
lernen sie dass leute aus deutschland
einen festen händedruck mögen dass es
menschen aus anderen kulturen gibt die
das nicht mögen dass es leute gibt die
europäer oder westler denen man in die
augen schauen kann und aber auch asiaten
bei denen man das nicht tun sollte
solche erfahrungen könnten sie nicht
machen ohne das volunteer programm
die männer nennen die europäerin machen
witze aber manchmal ist es gut mehr als
eine form zu haben wenn meine frau ein
kind hat dann muss sich doch jemand
anderen haben zudem ich gehen kann
für die zeit die sie mit dem baby
verbringt brauchst du an jedem einzelnen
tag eine frau an seiner seite
ja ja ich mag das nicht verständlich
würde mein mann eine zweite frau
heiraten ich würde beide umbringen mit
heißem wasser überschütten
man könnte ich nicht sagen das ist
schreckt so solltest mit deiner frau im
spital sein wenn sie das kind zur welt
bringt du solltest bei er sei nicht sie
verlassen
glaubst du alle frauen sehen das so wie
du
vor allem diejenigen die zur schule
gehen
[Musik]
bevor ich hier angefangen habe mit den
volontären zu sprechen habe ich gedacht
das weiße menschen eine spezielle rasse
sind
ich dachte dass maschinen alle arbeiten
für sie erledigen
aber als sich mit den volontären zu
sprechen begann
aber ich angefangen zu realisieren das
weiße normale menschen sind wie wir
[Musik]
nun macht auf gute laune er und hussein
sind von der jagd zum lagerplatz
zurückgekehrt erfolglos die offenbaren
heute schlauer als wir nächstes mal
überlisten wir sehen dafür waren andere
erfolgreiche ein wildschwein um das 70
kilo schwere tier tragen zu können haben
die jäger es gleich nach dem abschuss
zerlegt obwohl durch die rodungen in den
übrig gebliebenen urwaldgebieten immer
weniger tiere zu finden sind
wildschweine gibt es noch genug
bewundert allmählich verdaut dass
ausgerechnet er heute als jäger nicht
erfolgreich war
er kennt auch den grund dafür die zwei
anderen gruppen verließen natürlich die
wege wie beim jahren üblich und
präventiv
wir sind wegen eurer kamera er auf den
wegen geblieben haben darum die spur
davon verloren
[Musik]
nein
georgia nie wieder einmal in einem neuen
outfit ihre helfer fanden ist das
passendste für das interview mit einer
großen thailändischen tageszeitung
[Musik]
ich bin von der nation
danke das ist meine karte wo eine
wunderschöne card lotterie höflich
entgegenkommend gibt vor für die
fotografen und journalisten alles zu tun
und doch behält sie stets alles im griff
[Musik]
im interview geht es vor allem um ihr
aussehen
die interviewer ihn will wissen wie sie
es schaffe so schlank wir würden mager
sagen zu bleiben
die antwort ist denkbar einfach ich habe
mir eine grenze gesetzt
wenn ich 49 kilo bin ist das okay wenn
ich aber 49 anhalt bin esse ich am
nächsten tag weniger wenn du dich gehen
lässt bist du bald 51 52 53 kilo
dann wird es sehr schwer wieder
abzunehmen setzt sie ein ziel und halte
es ein
juli wird oft auf ihr äußeres reduziert
und wir fragen uns wie hält es die
unternehmerin mit der emanzipation im
job verbringe ich die meiste zeit aber
am ende des tages ist meine familie das
wichtigste für mich und es ist für mich
sehr wichtig meinen ehemann zu
unterstützen
vor allem wenn wir in der öffentlichkeit
sind ich habe die unterstützende rolle
zu übernehmen weil ich immer noch eine
asiatische frau bin
wir haben unserem anzudienen und das ist
für mich sehr wichtig
[Musik]
der letzte tag im urwald von bakbone und
ein gefährte vermessen die letzten
stellen via gps der rest der gruppe
kümmert sich um das mittagessen wie
pennern die jäger und sammler dieses
nomadenvolks sie kannten keinen getreide
oder kartoffelanbau ihrem bedarf an
kohlenhydraten gewannen sie aus den
lagerräumen der sago baum hat ein
weiches fahriges holz das sehr viel
stärker enthält in einem aufwendigen
verfahren wird die stärke aus dem holz
gewonnen
[Musik]
das entspannter arbeiten in der gruppe
inspiriert hussein zum spiel auf seiner
nase flöte
um zu seiner musik fällt hoch seien auch
gleich noch ein liedtext eine
improvisation ein pennern was sozusagen
[Musik]
und wohin
die lage
berlin wir machen sondern hatten
[Musik]
niemand hatte kalu leben
nach zwei stunden ist die stärke aus dem
holz herausgepresst
die letzte mahlzeit dem urwald denn es
ist zeit zum aufbruch
das sind jetzt unsere letzten stunden im
primär volt wald kommen wir aus dem
urwald heraus und wir werden die straße
der holzfäller sehen wir werden die
holzfäller selber sehen wie sie unseren
urwald fällen ihr werdet sehen wie es
aussieht nachdem die holzfäller im wald
waren sie nehmen nicht nur die großen
bäume
sie nehmen alles mit
in der nächsten folge versuchten die
holzfäller auszuspionieren
kein ungefährliches unterfangen in
bangkok trifft sie auf einen mann der
ihr großes verspricht
doch sie sucht ihr heil auch anderswo
auftrieb us-besuch turbine ein dorf mit
klimaflüchtlingen und hat danach nur
noch eine hoffnung
und in kenia schließlich wird das leben
von mary von tag zu tag spannender und
sie schmiedet große pläne
dies und mehr in der nächsten folge der
äquator
breitengrad der extreme
der äquator mit globetrotter darm
spezialist für maßgeschneiderte reise
wald wie globetrotter punkt ch